the flagship ship horizon third
generation may have 16 cores and
overclock all the way to 5 gigahertz
[Music]
welcome to horace hobbies so as you guys
already know risin brought a lotta
bhaijan cpu market by introducing high
korkin CPUs for really good prices and
rising 2nd generation only made it
better by offering even higher core
clocks and grapes stock CPU coolers
currently second generation rising is
definitely the best value CPUs on the
market but second generation Rison is
what Intel would call a talked upgrade
where all the hardware and technical
things is pretty much identical to the
previous generation and there is really
just a core clock upgrade and that
pretty much is what rises in the second
generation is taking that into
consideration
Reisen third generation is going to be a
tick upgrade so there should be
significant improvements to rise in
third generation
so should you wait for rising third
generation and what should you expect
first before we delve into all the leaks
in rumors let's discuss what we know for
sure from AMD themselves and really
there's only two things that we know
from AMD themselves but these are two
crucial details
first of all rice and third generation
should be on the seventh animator
process and there has been no word of
any delays so we should be seeing that
and number to rise and third generations
should be supported by current
generation and previous generation
motherboards AMD has promised four
generations of am for support and so far
they have been delivering on this
promise so we should keep seeing this
moving forward next let's look at some
things that can be easily inferred on
based on previous generational gaps last
year with the first generation Rison AMD
did not offer stock CPU coolers with all
their CPUs but with second generation
they're offering great stock coolers
with all other CPUs and I think this was
a great addition to a lot of buyers and
so I'm pretty sure AMD will continue to
do this and ask for a price and he
actually lowered the price of their CPUs
from first generation to second
generation by a pretty significant
margin we probably cannot expect such a
drop again especially because of the new
seven animator process so the most
likely pricing apps rise and third
generation is going to be the same price
again second generation or it might go
back up to a
generation costed either way it is still
a really good value especially
considering that into hasn't even
launched her ten nanometer series yet so
finally here are the rumors surrounding
the third generation of rising there are
only a two so it should be quick first
of all the rise and seven flagship CPU
of third generation Verizon is expected
to be able to overclock all the way to
five years and this does make sense
especially considering the 2,700 X
already reaches 4.3 gigahertz and this
new 3700 X or whatever it will be called
will be able to take advantage of the 7
nanometer process as well even if it
doesn't overclock all the way to 5 you
Hertz I think we can safely assume that
it will at least reach four point seven
years considering previous generational
gaps
the second big rumor is that risin 7 may
have 12 or even 16 cores now this does
have some legitimacy considering that
AMD is pushing it to 24 and 32 cores
under the thread Ripper series so they
may push 12 and 16 cores onto the
mainstream platform also with Intel
bringing out an 8 core CPU this year
aim D has to fight that and Andy is not
well known for their clock speeds so AMD
may indeed add more cores in order to
better combat that so while that rumor
may have some truth to it
I don't think AMD will offer so many
cores on the mainstream platform because
simply most people and most games don't
even take advantage of it in the first
place also I doubt AMD wants to have a
gap in their CPU lineup like for example
the risin 5 chips have 6 cores and died
they would want their rise in 7 CPUs
to go straight to 12 or 16 cores so I do
think a core current increase may happen
but I do not think that I will go all
the way to 12 or 16 cores so here's what
I think is a lot more likely so with the
first generation risin a MIDI already
learned at three identical rising 7 CPUs
is quite pointless and as a result with
rising 2nd generation they only launched
to the 2700 and the 2700 eggs so as a
result with third generation I think
they will do is same was at the 3730 700
X which will both be 8 core 16 thread
CPUs with the 3700 being able to
overclock to 4 point
224.50 hurts and at 3,700 racks being
able to overclock to four point seven to
five he hurts and both of these chips
will most likely come in around $350 and
it may be even less knowing aim D and
they will most likely be separated by a
$30 price gap so that will sufficiently
covered the octa-core space for AMD and
allowed them to fight Intel Core 4 core
and what we may see after that is a
3,800 X which may have more cores I
don't think it'll have 12 or 16 cores
because I do think that's a lot more
than what people need in the mainstream
platform but what I do think is likely
is maybe a 10 core CPU this way it's not
way over the top while still providing a
good upgrade over 3700 X unlike the 1800
X which was not really that much better
than the 1700 X and the 3800 X will most
likely be able to overclock in the low 4
range and it come in at 400 or maybe
$500 like the 1800 X so that's pretty
much what we can expect out of third
generation Rison so should you guys wait
for it well most of you guys probably
aren't looking at the 10 core CPU and if
you are then you should also consider
the I $9.99 hundred K from Intel because
that will most likely have around the
same performance as a 10 core chip and
in tow is still a really good option in
terms of performance and as a result the
answer is really quite simple if you are
happy with what you have and you can
wait for a couple of more months till
the rise and third generation comes out
next March then you should definitely
wait for it if you can because it does
provide a pretty good performance
upgrade over rise in second generation
and you can beyond the seven nanometer
process as well
however if you really need an upgrade
then you should just go ahead and buy
the second generation rising chips
because they are still really good value
and deliver really good performance
overall third generation Rises upgrades
will be pretty significant however the
only game changer chip that may be
available will be the high-end 3800 X so
unless you are considering that chip it
doesn't really matter if you wait or
just buy right now it really comes down
to personal preference if you can wait a
little bit longer and want the extra
speed and beyond the seven animator
process they usually consider waiting
for it rising third generation but if
you really know
we just go thrice and second generation
because it is still really good at the
end of the day it doesn't really matter
and it is just what makes you happier
but that's just what I think what do you
guys think do you guys think it's worth
it to wait for a rise in 3rd generation
or should you just buy 2nd generation
rising right now make sure to comment
down below what you guys think because I
do read all my comments and I'm curious
as to what you guys think so make sure
to post your thoughts also if you guys
like sphere then make sure to LIKE and
consider subscribing if you would like
to see more videos just like this one
but until next time bye
[Music]